MARCIA NUNES: Hi.
Happy Women's Day.
So I'm Marcia Nunes.
And as Karen said, I am
the merchandising manager
for Google Play
in Latin America.
So what that means is I pick
what apps and games and books
and movies and music we
feature in the region.
And I'm also a movie producer.
So I-- oh, yeah, is this better?
OK.
I'll just lean into the mic.
I'm also a movie producer.
I just finished my
first feature film.
And we'll be premiering
at the Tribeca Film
Festival in just over a month.
So, really exciting.
[APPLAUSE] Thank you.
And I'm here to talk to you
guys about how technology
is changing the playing field
for female content creators.
And it's a pretty big topic.
So I'm just going to focus--
FEMALE SPEAKER: You can use the
mic that's on the [INAUDIBLE].
MARCIA NUNES: Better?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Oh yeah.
MARCIA NUNES: Oh, great.
Sorry.
I can't really get a sense of
how it's projecting from here.
And this is good because
then I can move around.
I'm here to talk about
how technology is changing
the playing field for
female content creators.
And I'll just focus on film.
Because that's what I know best.
But most of this can apply to
video games, music, publishing,
et cetera.
There's lots of
cool ways that tech
is acting as an
equalizer in this really
male-dominated field.
But there's still lots
of problems and lots
of opportunities for disruption.
So I'm here hoping
that I will inspire
some of you young engineers
and maybe some of you engineers
who are a little bored
in what you're doing
and want to change
something else.
I'm here to inspire you to
create some new solutions.
So for those of you who don't
know, women's representation
in film, both behind the scenes
and in the stories themselves,
is really, laughably, low.
I don't know if anybody watched
the Oscars last weekend.
But Cate Blanchett talked about
this in her acceptance speech.
She said, "to those of us in
the industry who are still
foolishly clinging to the idea
that female films with women
at the center are niche
experiences-- they are not.
"Audiences want to see them.
And in fact, they earn money.
The world is round, people."
So let me just tell you
guys a bit about the numbers
to give you a sense of the
issue that we're facing.
Of the 250 top-grossing films in
the US in 2011, only 5% of them
were directed by women.
Only 14% of them were
written by women.
And only 25% of the
producers were women.
So these numbers have
fluctuated very little
since 1998, which means that the
traditional Hollywood model is
a huge impediment to access
for women filmmakers.
And why is that?
So trying to figure that out.
Last year, the Sundance
Institute and Women In Film
did a study called, "Exploring
the Barriers for Opportunities
for Women Filmmakers."
And they went through
all these numbers.
And they also interviewed
hundreds of filmmakers
to try and get a
sense of the problems.
And from this study,
from these interviews,
five main barriers
to entry emerged.
The first two go together.
And they're, gendered
financial barriers
and male-dominated networks.
So what does this mean?
That in movies, as in most other
things, men control the money.
So if the men are in charge
of the funding sources
and these male
financiers are not
as interested in
women's stories,
women's stories are
not getting funded.
And they're not getting seen.
The other issue is that
female-centric projects
are perceived to lack
commercial viability.
So traditionally,
the assumption is
that women will go watch
"Thor" and "The Avengers"
and other male-centered films.
But men are not going
to do the same thing
for female-centered films.
Now, last year, two
of the biggest hits
were "Frozen," which is awesome,
by the way, and "Hunger Games,"
obviously proving this wrong.
Before that, you
had "Bridesmaids."
You had "Twilight."
You have tons of
examples that show
that female-centric
films do make money.
But still, Hollywood sticks
to the old assumptions.
And the slate skews highly male.
So some of the other problems
that female filmmakers are
faced with is
stereotyping onset,
meaning that people don't think
women can direct action scenes,
even though Catherine Bigelow
has been doing it for years.
And people don't
think females can
direct huge crews full of men.
Lack of work and family
balance-- which we know
is an issue everywhere.
And exclusionary
hiring decisions--
So Katherine Hardwick,
who's the director
of the "Twilight" franchise,
has spoken pretty openly
about being denied studio jobs.
Because they just wouldn't
trust a woman with a project
that's very large.
And you guys might
be thinking, well,
I kind of like "Thor," I
kind of like "Avengers."
I think things in
film are pretty good.
Why should I work
to change this?
Why should I be
creating platforms
that will help
female filmmakers?
And I think that it's because
if we consider our culture
to be a reflection
of who we are,
to have a film culture
without women's voices
contributing a
significant amount
is a really limited reflection
of who we are as a whole.
And it's also a reflection--
you can see this
because in the top 250 movies,
again, of 2011, only 11%
of the main
characters were women.
78% were men.
And in another study
of over 900 movies,
they found that violence,
blood, gore, weapons,
they were much less
likely to be seen
in a female-driven project.
And thought-provoking
topics were much more
likely to be seen.
And having women in lead
positions in film also
increases the overall
number of women
that are working on a project.
So the Sundance
Institute found that when
a man directs a film, on average
23% of the key positions,
meaning producers, writers,
editors, cinematographer--
only 23% of those positions
are held by women.
When a woman directs a
film, 44% of those roles
are held by women.
This is a much better ratio.
And we're creating
jobs for more women.
So what are some solutions
to even the playing field?
The same women that offered
up the five barriers to entry
also suggested the
following-- improving access
to finance, mentoring
and encouragement
for early career women,
and raising awareness
of the problem, like
I'm here doing today.
So how is tech helping
to address some of these?
Firstly, access
to funding-- we're
all probably familiar
with crowd funding, where
you fund or partially fund
your project with support
from your future audience,
people who are already
interested in the product.
So Kickstarter's the big
one that we've all heard of.
There's also tons
of other models.
Kickstarter and Indiegogo
mostly are rewards-based.
People contribute in
exchange for prizes.
They don't expect to
get their money back.
There is Slated
and IndieVest that
are now, with the JOBS
Act, raising money
through crowd funding, but
for equity investments.
So people do get
their money back.
And there's one
called CineCoup that's
kind of an audience
participation, American Idol
film competition, where people
post trailers, the audience
votes on them.
And the best one gets
funded by the company.
And there's one
called Seed&Spark,
which is focused on
female-driven films.
And it's also a nonexclusive
distribution platform.
And they curate it,
so that you really
have to prove to them that
you can attract an audience.
You have to prove your vision
to them before they even
let you start your
crowd funding.
So it's pretty cool.
There hasn't yet been a study of
how many crowd-funded films are
female-driven.
And I would love to
see those numbers.
Because I think they
will be much more equal
than Hollywood films.
But there has been some
high-profile successes
for women on these sites.
And a big one is about to come
out in theaters on March 14.
And that's "Veronica
Mars," which
is a show starring Kristen
Bell as a plucky student
detective that was
beloved by many
but watched by only 2 and 1/2
million people a week, which
for Hollywood is not enough.
So Warner Brothers
cancelled that show.
And Kristen Bell and
the show's creator
went to Warner Brothers.
And they said, if we can raise
$2 million on Kickstarter,
will you make a movie of it?
Warner Brothers said OK.
And it was the
largest film goal ever
on Kickstarter at the time.
They ended up
raising $5.7 million
from over 91,000 people.
And the studio funded
the rest of the movie,
which only cost
about $6 million.
So Warner Brothers really
got a good deal out of that.
And now it's coming
out in theaters.
On a smaller scale,
Jodie Foster just
recently narrated
a documentary about
the first female director.
It's called "Be Natural."
And that raised
$219,000 on Kickstarter.
And my movie raised $60,000 on
Kickstarter, which was great.
Because without it,
we would not have
been able to get the
production going on time.
So we really needed that gap.
Another huge
development in a way
that tech is influencing
the industry right
now is the direct
access to audience.
So we all know there's a
myriad of different platforms
where you can watch content.
And we're not relying on
linear TV programming.
So that basically
means that we can
watch what we want to watch
when we want to watch it.
In 2006, Chris Anderson wrote
a book called, "The Long Tail."
And the book is about how with
the rise on my distribution
there is going to be the demise
of the hit-driven mindset,
which for movies means those
tent pole action movies.
And what he was saying is that
on stores like Google Play
and iTunes and
Amazon and Netflix,
people can browse
the infinite isle.
And that is a digital store
with limitless inventory
It means that you don't have
to watch the blockbusters that
are always in your face.
You can watch, via
personalization
and via merchandising,
you can watch
what actually
interests you, not what
the studios are
telling you to watch.
And you can see the
proof of how this works
and how our interests
are actually
very diverse in the
way that money is now
made in online distribution.
So after the book came
out, Reed Hastings,
who is the CEO Netflix,
told Chris Anderson
that Blockbuster made 90% of
their revenue from new releases
when they had physical stores.
Netflix only relies
on new releases
for 30% of their revenue.
So that means that
people are actually
looking for their
true interests.
They don't want to
watch those movies.
They want to watch
different movies.
And these are giving
women more opportunities
to get their content noticed.
There's also lots of
fun, other platforms,
like TUG, which is a website
that allows you to crowd fund
to get your movie actually
in a movie theater.
So it usually costs
about $5,000 to $20,000
to get into a movie
theater if you're
an independent filmmaker.
And most people can't afford it.
So there's certain
online platforms
that allow you to pre-sell those
tickets so you can actually
fund your theater run
before you even get there.
So there's much less of a risk.
Going back to the
need for mentoring
and raising
awareness-- obviously,
we use social media to get
the word out about films
all the time now, from
the crowd funding stage
to the distribution stage.
Lots of people think that the
big benefit of crowd funding
is not only that you get
money for your project,
but also that you have
a built-in audience.
Social media also
puts a public face
to the mentor-mentee
relationships,
which is really important now.
Because one of the downsides
of relying on crowd
funding is that
you basically need
an audience to buy into you
before you create your content.
So having ways for some public
figure whose work is already
widely respected to show
public support for an upcoming
filmmaker means
that that filmmaker
is going to have a much
easier time getting
funding on these
crowd sourcing sites,
and getting audience, et cetera.
So there's no study
yet, like I said,
of how all of this technology
is impacting women in film.
But we can look at recent
independent filmmaking
statistics to see
what's changing.
Because these are the
films that are getting
made through this technology.
So this year, 3,293 films
were submitted to Sundance.
Of them, 773 were
directed by women.
That's 23.4%.
Out of the 119 films that
were accepted in Sundance,
women directed 29%
of those films.
So not great numbers, still.
But about six times better
than the Hollywood figures.
So we're going in
the right direction.
But there's lots of things that
still need to be disrupted.
And like I said, TED
can't provide an answer
to all of them.
But I am hoping that you
guys will get inspired, build
more platforms that can
help other female content
creators to address
some of these issues.
So a couple of ideas-- one thing
that really needs disrupting
is the distribution model.
Because right now, even
though you can finance,
you can produce, you can reach
your audience without really
relying on the traditional
male-centric financing world,
you can't distribute
your movie, you
can't get money for your
movie without going back
into that world.
So to give you an
idea, even the smallest
of independent movies
that you'll probably
watch on Netflix or on
TV or on Google Play--
even the smallest
one of these movies
probably cost at least $100,000.
But without going into a
traditional distribution
company, it's really hard for
a filmmaker to get even half
of that.
So that means that their
investors aren't getting paid.
And it perpetuates the myth
that people aren't paying money
for female-driven content,
which is not true.
People are paying money.
But people are paying money
for things they can find.
They're not paying money for
movies they don't know exist.
So I know tech can't
fix this on its own.
But the more platforms
that are created for women
to distribute their films
and to collect payment
for that distribution-- that's
the really important part--
the more the traditional system
is going to have to shift.
And in that vein, we also
don't want the film world
to get too niche.
We don't want a world where
your future choices are all
decided by an
algorithm that is only
looking at your past choices.
We want a world
where one day you
can watch "Wadjda," which was
a great foreign film last year
about a little girl who's
entering a bike competition.
But then the next day,
you can turn around
and watch an explosion
bonanza like "White House
Down," if you want to.
Those are also fun.
So we want to open our horizons.
We want to get the
most films out there.
We don't want to trap everybody
in individualized little boxes.
Crowd funding is also
still incredibly difficult
if you're not a celebrity
like Kristen Bell
and if you don't have
an established audience.
So most people end up
raising their money
from their own
personal networks.
So how can we build
something that
will allow upcoming female
filmmakers to reach a wider
group of people?
What can we build
that won't rely
so much on your current
network, but will
look at your network's network
and that extended network
and bring people from all
of those places together?
Finally, women are
not the only ones
that are underrepresented in
the entertainment industry.
Every other minority has equally
low numbers or even lower.
And it doesn't do
much to just fight
for equal representation
for women filmmakers
and forget about everybody else.
So we need to really be
thinking of solutions
that will allow filmmakers
of all genders, all races,
all creeds, all
sexual orientations
to tell their stories.
And only then will
we have a culture
that's truly reflective
of who we are.
Thank you.
And if anyone has any
questions-- All right.
AUDIENCE: I'll ask a question.
MARCIA NUNES: Sure.
AUDIENCE: I really
enjoyed your talk.
It was interesting.
So you're a filmmaker
and you work for Google.
All of these alternative
models, are they really
viable to make a living
as an independent artist?
Or are you going to rely on
some sort of patronage model
like crowd funding?
That sort of thing.
MARCIA NUNES: Well, that's
a really pertinent question.
Right now, most
artists can't just
make a living being artists.
So everybody needs an
alternate source of income.
I do think that a
patronage model is probably
going to happen very soon, crowd
funding, but also organizations
like film societies
that give grants
to artists and everything.
I think we are going
back to that world
with any kind of
independent art phenomenon.
But it's hard.
I mean, I don't sleep.
That's how I do it.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Super great talk.
I really enjoyed
listening to you.
So my question-- you talked
a little about distribution.
But would you recommend
any portals online
that we can go to
to currently find
women-directed and
women-told stories that
are in film or in TV right now?
MARCIA NUNES: Yeah, definitely.
So one that I mentioned
was Seed&Spark.
So that is a crowd funding site.
But they're also a
distribution platform.
And they are definitely
focused only on women.
But I would say, also, that any
of the big on demand platforms
will have a section, probably,
that's like women filmmakers
or something that, even if
it's-- like Netflix is known
for having famously funny, very
specific categories that are
targeted exactly to you.
So I think it's easier to
find female-driven content
on these sites than
it would be to go
to a actual physical store
and get it on the shelf.
There's also really
great resources
by a company called
Women In Film.
And that's a nonprofit that
highlights women in film.
So they actually
have a great catalog
of films directed and
produced by women or just
about women's stories.
And if you click
on movies there,
they'll tell you where
you can buy them online,
which is pretty cool.
Well, thank you so much.
Enjoy your lunch.
Oh, one more?
OK.
AUDIENCE: It's a
pretty simple question.
But can you tell
us about your film?
MARCIA NUNES: Oh, sure.
So my film is called,
"Manos Sucias."
And we shot it in
Colombia last year.
And it's a narrative film.
It's about the drug
trade in Colombia.
It's about two
brothers that haven't
spoken to each other
in several years.
And they, unbeknownst
to each other,
end up on the same drug run.
And it just takes a look
at life on the lowest
rung of the
international drug trade
and how they're not the people
that are driving this at all.
But they're the
people whose lives
are most negatively
affected by it.
April 17.
[LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm a developer.
And I've also worked
on a few film projects,
mostly in San Francisco in a
group that encouraged everybody
to do these projects for
free, which is really great.
Do you know of any
groups like that
in New York City that
encourages, also,
just women, as well, just to
do directing, producing, create
groups together?
MARCIA NUNES: Yeah.
Well, I know there is,
again, Women In Film.
They have a branch in
New York and in LA.
There's also a
really great group
called Chicken and
Egg Productions.
And they're not group per se.
But they're a company
that specializes
in female-driven projects.
And if you have an
idea for a project,
they're the people that
you would take it to.
AUDIENCE: Can I also
add one more thing?
It's a little bit
related to the last one.
I wanted to say something.
I'm curious as to
the next generation--
because I think I'm a
little older than you--
because the last speaker spoke
about feeling not supported
in technology.
And also, obviously, in film
we're not supported enough.
And it disappoints
me a little bit
to hear women are so focused
on finding men or trying
to impress men and not
show their inner nerd
and strength, versus finding
men that are very supportive
and encouraging those men
to be stronger and more
confident in themselves to be
able to accept strong women.
And so I'm wondering
how people-- maybe it's
a group question,
really-- are women
still feeling like they have
to really conform to this more
feminine way so that we're
accepted versus being strong
and finding these men
and maybe raising--
I want to raise
the next generation
and have friends that raise the
next generation of boys that
can be really strong enough
to accept strong women.
So I'm just curious about that.
What is your experience?
MARCIA NUNES: Well,
I definitely don't
know if I can speak
for all women.
I think that's something
that a lot, a lot of women
struggle with.
I see a lot of my friends
struggling with it.
I am incredibly
lucky that I married
a man who lets me be my
weird, nerdy, crazy self
and sing on the sidewalks.
And he doesn't care.
And it's awesome.
I think there are men like that.
One thing I didn't
mention is that my movie
is directed by a man, in fact.
So I'm here talking
about women filmmakers.
But I'm working
on a movie that's
written and directed by men.
And they're both awesome,
super sensitive guys.
And I think those
guys are out there.
And I think that the women,
not of your generation,
I think the women of the
generation above that that are
raising the guys today
did a really good job.
But there's always
going to be assholes
that don't support strong women.
And I think we just need to stop
giving them the time of day.
AUDIENCE: No, I agree.
I had a really
strong father that
really supported me to
do whatever I wanted.
And he was a mathematician.
And he just helped me say,
go do whatever you want.
And my husband is same way.
So I'm hoping
everybody-- well, I
would love to support
everybody that
would want to find a man that's
stronger versus you needing
to feel like you
have to be less.
So anyway, I was just curious.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]